Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Mitri
Sirin in allen schönen guten Abend
Reaktionen und Bilder vom Fußball WM
Spiel der deutschen Frauen später bei
dir Katja es gab einige enttäuschte
Gesichter schönen guten Abend unsere
sonntagsthemen
wieder Drohnenangriffe auf Moskau
gleichzeitig demonstriert russlands
Präsident in St Petersburg Stärke
10.000 Demonstranten auf den Straßen von
Tel Aviv der Widerstand gegen die
Justizreform App nicht ab
und bittere Niederlage bei der WM die
deutschen Fußballerinnen verlieren in
der Nachspielzeit gegen Kolumbien
[Musik]
bei russischen Raketenangriffen auf die
süd-ukraine sind vier Menschen ums Leben
gekommen aber auch Russland wurde
getroffen es ist nämlich wieder passiert
erneut wurde die Hauptstadt von mehreren
Drohnen attackiert im Wolkenkratzer
Viertel der Metropole wo auch
Ministerien ihren Sitz haben wurden
Bürogebäude getroffen das
Verteidigungsministerium macht Kia für
die Angriffe verantwortlich Oliver
Flammen berichtet
es ist eines von Mosk aus neuen
vorzeigegebäuden ein 50-stöckiger
Wolkenkratzer mitten in der Innenstadt
ein Wachmann wurde bei dem Angriff
offenbar verletzt
ich bin von diesem fürchterlichen Krach
aufgewacht und dachte zuerst das käme
von einem Gewitter
wir hörten die Explosion und spürten die
Druckwelle dann war überall Rauch und
von oben kam Feuer
die Ukraine habe Moskau mit Drohnen
angegriffen so das russische
Verteidigungsministerium doch Experten
bezweifeln dass Drohnen aus der Ukraine
hunderte Kilometer über russisches
Gebiet fliegen könnten ohne von der
Luftabwehr abgeschossen zu werden eine
mögliche Erklärung ein Sabotageakt aus
der direkten Umgebung Moskau
der Angriff kommt an einem symbolischen
Tag am Tag der Marine nimmt Präsident
Putin in St Petersburg die Parade der
russischen Seekriegsflotte ab ungewohnt
offen hatte er erst gestern darüber
gesprochen dass sein Land in einem
bewaffneten Konflikt mit einem
Nachbarland sei das so Putin erfordere
auch Repressionen und härten gegenüber
kritischen Stimmen im eigenen Land
den bewaffneten Konflikt mit der Ukraine
wie er jetzt genannt wird führt Russland
weiter mit aller Härte bei
Raketenangriffen unter anderem auf eine
Berufsschule in Sumi starben mehrere
Menschen putzende wurden verletzt
vor der niederländischen Küste hat ein
bergungskommando jetzt doch damit
begonnen den brennenden Auto Frachter zu
einem provisorischen Ankerplatz zu
schleppen wie die zuständige
Wasserbehörde am Nachmittag mitteilte
hat der giftige Rauch auf der Free
mental Highway deutlich nachgelassen
zudem habe man eine zusätzliche
schleppverbindung herstellen können
wegen starker Rauchentwicklung und
heftigem Wind war die abschleppaktion
zunächst abgesagt worden
wir müssen uns jetzt wieder stärker auf
den Osten fokussieren das sagt Martin
Schirdewahn Vorsitzender der Linken im
ZDF sommerinterview denn während die AFD
dort immer stärker wird hängt seine
Partei eigentlicher tiefer wurzelt in
aus Deutschland im Umfrage tief können
wir uns mal anschauen im letzten ZDF
Politbarometer vor zwei Wochen da war
die Linke bundesweit wieder unter die
fünf Prozent gerutscht und die
Brandmauer zur AFD ist auch bei der
Linken großes Thema Daniel pontzen
trotz öffentlich geäußerte Empörung über
gemeinsames abstimmen mit der AFD auf
kommunaler Ebene hat es bereits mehrere
Fälle gegeben wo genau dies auch bei der
Linken der Fall war na gut wenn einzelne
sozusagen in einer Situation so
reagieren aber die Partei dann trotzdem
geschlossen zeigt dass das nicht geht
dann ist das auch richtig das ist doch
klar dass die parteiposition ist
Konsequenzen etwa in Form eingeleitete
Parteiausschlussverfahren gab es
allerdings nicht jedes mal gerade im
Osten der einstigen Bastion ist die
Linke zunehmend im Klammergriff von AFD
und eine möglichen neuen Partei mit
ihren Gründung sie kokettiert woraufhin
der Linken Vorstand beschloss die
Zukunft der Linken sei eine Zukunft ohne
Sarah Wagenknecht wir können über alles
intern reden aber intern wir können alle
Konflikte intern lösen aber eine
Neugründung aus dieser Partei heraus das
ist tabu und das trägt im übrigen die
Partei auch mit dass man mit der
Nominierung von seenotretterinnen und
klimaaktivistin Carola Rakete für die
Europawahl am klassischen Klientel
vorbei Ziele gar eine vergrünisierung
der partei-drohe wie manche fürchten dem
widersprach der Parteichef ganz im
Gegenteil wir sind natürlich in unserer
Klimaschutzpolitik radikaler als die
Grünen weil wir das auch als eine
antikapitalistische Politik begreifen
weil wir sehen dass insbesondere die
Superreiche mit ihrem Lebensstil die
Umwelt so verschmutzen dass aber dann am
Ende die armen dafür zahlen soll
wegweisend für die Partei dürfte vor
allem das nächste Jahr werden dann
stehen neben der Europawahl in
Ostdeutschland drei Landtags und viele
Kommunalwahlen an
das komplette sommerinterview mit Linken
chefschede waren gleich direkt im
Anschluss an unsere Sendung
nach dem Putsch im westafrikanischen
Niger spitzt sich die Lage weiter zu
angrenzende Staaten drohen den prozisten
mit Gewalt wenn sie die Macht nicht dem
gestützten Präsidenten bazoom
wiedergeben in der Hauptstadt Miami
demonstrierten Anhänger der neuen
Machthaber teils mit Gewalt viele
forderten eine Neuausrichtung hin zu
Russland und mehr Unabhängigkeit von der
ehemaligen Kolonialmacht Frankreich
dabei zogen sie auch vor die
französische Botschaft
bei einem Selbstmordanschlag in Pakistan
sind mindestens 40 Menschen ums Leben
gekommen Ziel war eine Veranstaltung
einer konservativ islamischen Partei im
Nordwesten des Landes die Region gilt
als hochbuchradikaler Islamisten sowohl
der sogenannte islamische Staat als auch
die Taliban wurden zuletzt für
Terrorakte dort verantwortlich gemacht
wieder gab es Maßen Demonstrationen in
Israel gegen die hoch umstrittene
Justizreform das israelische Fernsehen
berichtet von mehr als 170.000
Demonstranten allein in Tel Aviv die
rechtsreligiöse Regierung hatte wichtige
Teile der Reform gerade erst durchs
Parlament gebracht durch das geplante
Gesetz werden die Befugnisse des
obersten Gerichtes stark beschnitten
Stefanie gagusch
sie gehen weiter auf die Straßen kämpfen
lautstark für ihre Demokratie
[Musik]
wieder kamen Massen zu den Protesten in
der letzten Nacht in Tel avival
Jerusalem landesweit denn auch wenn sie
einen Teil der umstrittenen Justizreform
nicht verhindern konnten aufgeben werden
sie nicht
weil die Regierung von nettern ja nicht
stoppen wird sie wollen alle Gerichte
kontrollieren das ganze Justizsystem
keine Regierung kann diese Massen auf
Dauer ignorieren wir werden
weiterkämpfen weiter demonstrieren und
das tägliche Leben hier unterbrechen wir
werden den Aufstand weiter und
weitertragen
es sind die ersten großen Proteste nach
dem Beschluss der rechtsreligiösen
Regierung die Gerichte teilweise zu
schwächen manche hatten gedacht sie
würden abflauen das Gegenteil der Fall
das israelische Parlament geht ab morgen
in die Sommerpause leise wird es dann
aber wohl nicht im Land denn die
Protestler haben angekündigt ihre Kritik
an der Regierung von Eltern ja weiter zu
intensivieren jede Art ziviler
Ungehorsam sein unmöglich verkündet
schick mal Bresler eine Anführerin der
Demonstranten
ihr alle hier habt uns zu verstehen
gegeben dass wir die Protestbewegungen
noch stärker machen müssen und das
werden wir tun
Israel ist tief gespalten und trinkt
weiter um seine Demokratie
in Südtirol haben gestern Abend Unwetter
gewütet verletzt wurde niemand aber es
gab schwere Schäden der Starkregen ließ
im Pustertal Bäche derart anstellen dass
sie mehrere Holzbrücken mit sich rissen
Schutt und Schlamm blockierten außerdem
Straßen und beschädigten Gebäude und
östlich von Bozen ging eine
geröll-lawine ab dadurch wurden mehrere
Autos auf einem Parkplatz verschüttet
jetzt so Fußball WM der Frauen da liest
für Deutschland nicht so gut Katja man
kann sagen aus deutscher Sicht war das
zweite Gruppenspiel im Stadion von
Sydney 7 Minuten zu lang denn der 2:1
Siegtreffer der Kolumbianerinnen gegen
das deutsche Team fehlt tatsächlich in
der Nachspielzeit
das von der ersten Minute an hart und
kämpfte Match muss bis zu 52 Minute auf
seinen ersten echten Höhepunkt warten
als die 18-Jährige Linda kaissedo von
Real Madrid Kolumbien sehenswert mit 1:0
in Führung schießt danach spielt das
deutsche Team wie ausgewechselt uns kam
durch Kapitän in Alexandra Popp per
Strafstoß in der 89 minute ausgleichen
als sich alle dann schon mit dem
Unentschieden arrangiert haben köpft
Manuela war [__] in der 7 Minute der
Nachspielzeit Kolumbien doch noch zum
nicht und verdienten Sieg das
enttäuschte und enttäuschende deutsche
Team wird nun am Donnerstag gegen
Südkorea ein anderes Gesicht zeigen
müssen
und hier die Ergebnisse der anderen
Spiele von heute Marokko gewinnt in der
Gruppe der Deutschen gegen Südkorea 1:0
die Schweiz steht nach dem 0:0 gegen
Neuseeland als Sieger der Gruppe A im
Achtelfinale die Neuseeländerinnen
hingegen sind ausgeschieden dafür auch
im Achtelfinale Norwegen nach dem 6.0
gegen die Philippinen endlich ist der
Kindheitstraum in seiner Geburt statt
erfüllt Alexander Zverev hat das
ATP-Turnier am Hamburger Rothenbaum
gewonnen als erste deutscher Spieler
seit Michael Stich vorhin zwischen 30
Jahren es wäre es besiegte den Serben
Laszlo Jere mit sieben zu fünf und sechs
zu drei und blieb damit das gesamte
Turnier über ohne Satzverlust der
kullerte sogar ein freudentränchen
so Formel 1 Weltmeister Max Verstappen
hat auch den Grand Prix von Belgien ins
Spa gewonnen sein Red Bull Teamkollege
Sergio Paris wurde Zweiter vor Ferrari
Pilot Charlie Clark
die Gesamtsiegerin der zweiten Ausgabe
der Tour de France der Frauen kommt aus
den Niederlanden und heißt Demi vor
lehring die achte und letzte Etappe
dieser Tour ein 22,6 Kilometer
Zeitfahren gewann aber eine andere
nämlich die Schweizer Europameisterin
Marleen äußer ja und Ricarda Bauernfeind
wurde beste deutsche in der
Gesamtwertung auf Rang 9 katja hat
vielen Dank wir schauen noch auf die
Wetteraussichten im Norden teils
kräftiger und langanhaltender Regen
vereinzelt auch Gewitter im Süden
weitgehend trocken und größere sonnige
Abschnitte bei lebhaft im Südwestwind 18
bis 26 Grad die weiteren Aussichten ja
sehr unbeständig und windig bei
ähnlichen Temperaturen
um 21:45 Uhr empfehlen wir das heute
journal mit Dunja Hayali wir sehen uns
morgen um 7 Uhr und Sie hier gleich das
ZDF sommerinterview mit linken Chef
Martin schönen Dank und schönen Abend